[Music]
Tom Cruise on besides being a great
actor who knew that he was a little bit
of an exhibitionist Carly well I mean if
you were as handsome as Tom Cruise why
not write american-made start clearly
does his own stunts even when the script
calls for a little nudity you're cheeky
in this film yogurt and I'm not just
some cheeky tree that's what that
character did and he always flash his
wife there's a lot of mooning going on
Tom's a renegade pilot who occasionally
drops trou in American maids and it
seems when he poses with fans in real
life well some get a little handsy
people are always asking you for
photographs and the husband's take
photos of you with their wives but a lot
of the wives grab your bottom while
you're being photographed it does happen
yes it does it occasionally this is how
michael cera right olson is Tom's
on-screen wife she's married to NCIS Los
Angeles star Eric Christian Olsen who
just so happens to be a Tom Cruise
superfan I was on the phone with my
husband when I got to Atlanta for the
audition and my phone was ringing and I
was like oh I don't know this number he
said take it it's probably Tom well it
was I was like phone with him and then
of course I call my husband back no like
you were right it was him oh my gosh I
don't even know what I dad it just kind
of blacked out
[Music]
you